[Music]
this pandemic isn't over
today we mark a tragic milestone here in
the united states
1 million covet deaths
1 million empty chairs around the family
dinner table
each
irreplaceable
irreplaceable losses each leaving behind
a family a community forever changed
because of this pandemic
morocco is out to all those who are
struggling
asking themselves
how do i go on without him how do god
without her
what will we do without him
it's grief shared by people across all
of our nations
around the world many more millions have
died
millions of children have been orphaned
and with thousands still dying every day
now is the time for us to act
all of us together
we all must do more we must honor
those we have lost by doing everything
we can to prevent as many deaths as
possible
our hearts go out to those grieving a
loved one and those families forever
changed because of the pandemic as the
president said this morning we cannot
grow numb to the urgency of this crisis
it is critical that we honor those who
have been lost by doing everything we
can to prevent as many deaths as
possible you saw that this morning from
from the president as he kicked off the
covet 19 summit today's summit
highlighted american leadership in
action together with our co-hosting
nations we uh we united the world to
commit to vaccinating the uh to
vaccinating the world saving lives and
building better health security with an
inspiring response we rallied three
billion dollars from other nations more
than three about 3.2 at this point in
time still counting
from other nations and partners around
the world to address the global response
and the president issued a stark warning
about our ability to continue fighting
clothed globally if congress fails to
act as we heard through the summit now
is not the time for complacency we need
congress to show up now with empty words
but with action to fight covet at home
and abroad as we mark this tragic
milestone our hope is to avoid another
tragic one like this
and that will only come if we act with
urgency
throughout the remaining fight against
the pandemic